now and and what about the science of
or the physics maybe of um
hitting the blades hitting the brakes
and flying right by so i was saying to
my friend will over the weekend i was
like i'm confused he pulls he pushes
forward and pulls back to me that feels
like he wouldn't go up and backwards but
is that correct or not
so i'm at the original top gun when he
does the original i think yeah yeah he
had the throttles backwards on that he
would have pulled him back popped his
speed brakes and to slow down as rapidly
as possible and pull directly up to also
create more parasite drag putting it
forward yeah so in an original top gun
he if he was doing it right he would
pull back with both hands and then push
forward with his feet is that right
well the feet are your rudder so pushing
forward wouldn't do anything uh good one
foot or the other is going to move your
rudder left or right so yeah feet would
have nothing to do with it but pulling
the throttle back to idle and pulling
the stick up to do
they refer to it kind of as a cobra
maneuver if you will
harmonize with me and hold through the
night you're shining bright i'm your
host
[Music]